as a believable message is based on
proof and evidence
what overtook you about Islam that had
you accepted Jesus was his messenger
Allah there's only one word Muhammad is
His Messenger
they're going greens apiece how you guys
doing another week another exciting
episode Alexander how you doing my
brother son I'll make only cancel on one
of us alone
please be with you likewise mother how's
everything good good hamdullah so it's
the billion dollar question I don't call
it a million dollar question call the
billion dollar question and that's why
you're here to share your story tell us
people usually nowadays like people are
thinking that hey if I'm gonna become a
Muslim you know that's probably like the
last thing that people are gonna have on
their list they'll join every other
religion you follow me because it's kind
of cool but nowadays there's so much
heat on Islam but you became a Muslim
how long ago was that that was 14 years
ago 14 years ago I don't know which
guest I asked was it was it at that time
was there as much when I say heat I mean
it's like all over the news as soon as
you say Muslim people start thinking
some ludicrous things you know
attributing to it terrorism and all
sorts of nonsense but what was it about
Islam but we still see Islam as being
the fastest growing way of life in the
world because as a believable message is
based on proof and evidence
what overtook you about Islam that had
you accepted what overtook me well
during that time I know there was like
the war in Iraq and it was shortly after
like the world trade center incident but
me accepting Islam had like I had no
idea who who it was that did that or
they had no impact on my you know
finding Islam I'd say primarily it was a
there was a friend of mine who told me
about Islam like over a course of
probably two or three months maybe you
tell you the Muslim friend of yours yeah
it's a Muslim friend of mine and what
was it about Islam that had you find
that had you accepted well after talking
with him for some time it had been
it would be on and off and we met
through non-muslim friends we were
mutual friends and from time to time
when he would invite me to his house he
would tell me a little bit about Islam
it wasn't the main focus of our of our
hangout time but from time to time he'd
bring it up he'd tell me what he thinks
and eventually I picked up my own book
on a bag if he had the Prophet peace be
upon him and read that and what really
took me were the letters that he sent to
the kings and the rulers at that time
inviting them to worship Allah alone and
so it was primarily the letters that's
what actually brought me to able to be
able to go to the mosque and take
Shahada there oh you see you so you're
talking about the time in history when
when Prophet Muhammad who we believe is
the last and final messenger in a line
of messengers and that kind of when you
explain that chronological order to
people it makes sense okay there was the
first man Adam he was told to submit his
will to God he was a Muslim that's what
a Muslim is you know the son is a Muslim
the trees him everything that submits
his will to God is a Muslim that's
simply what it means so when we start
with the first man Adam and then you
move along to all the other messengers
just to name a few Noah Abraham Moses
Jesus Mohammed it's that line you know
and it's the same one humanity one way
of life submit your will to the creator
of life the one who created life and do
good deeds you're gonna be accountable
for on the day of judgment you can't
just do whatever you want and live life
without a purpose a purpose so now when
you explain these things it just makes
sense and now when we study the life and
this is what you're referring to the
life of the last and final messenger
documented like no other human being
history this is amazing everything
everything that you need to know about
him it's documented so particularly this
is amazing he sent out letters to the
leaders at that time inviting them to
God inviting them to submission to the
crater not the creation to Islam and
that had a profound effect on you yeah
yeah that would be what was it about it
it was like
it was very straight to the point it was
no beating around the bush no beating
around the bush it was it was still kind
it was firm but it was it was very I
like what you said to the point it was
like worship God alone me worship Allah
the Creator I'm the messenger of God and
guaranteeing for the one who you know
and it goes on everything is kind of
outlined right it's not you know what's
you you can't read that letter and not
get the message right right and there
were multiple letters like that
obviously and but that was basically I
can't remember exactly what it was about
them specifically but I remember that
that's what had drawn me in because it's
been 14 years since but uh yeah and it
was shortly thereafter that my friend
invited me to come to the mosque and
Islam kind of like grew on me I would
say like a lot of times people become
Muslim and they think that it's just
like that yeah but a lot like a lot of
times I think later on in life is when
like two or three years after I became
Muslim that's when I actually started to
feel like I was really being Muslim
because then by then I started reading
and going to classes and stuff like that
on Islam somewhat took a while and then
actually I feel like a conversion
actually kind of like grew on me rather
than just like an immediate like
staining saying of the Shahada and it
was because a lot of people don't really
study the Deen they don't study Islam
like that like they might get to a
certain place in it and then they kind
of like they just they pray and they
fast but they don't really continue to
like learn which is very important I
think for people to maintain their Islam
and then grow also mm-hmm it's like
anything if you love it I mean you want
to really invest the time to get to know
it right you'll appreciate it more have
you seen that many people who hadn't
gone through the digging process like
you had to like do some work what I mean
like you did
and then you find that valuable treasure
of Islam you got many Muslims who are
just born with the nametag Muslim right
they didn't have to struggle and strive
and then he just they end up not
appreciating it taking it for granted
not implementing it being ignorant of it
doing the opposite of it right have you
seen that contradiction early and then
knowledge being the distinguishing
factor factor the extent acknowledged
when you have that makes a world of a
difference in those how long did it take
you to embrace Islam to know that okay
so we got one thing you mentioned the
letters but how much time did it take
all together before you were like you
know what this is really making sense
you know Islam has a believable message
worship one god only one guy there's no
intermediaries between you and God
you're not going to a confession box
you're not praying through a saint a
messenger anything in creation but the
one God the one who created this whole
universe the ultimate reality God
Almighty in Arabic Allah that message is
believable we have the Quran it's a
living testable miracle and I don't have
to sell you on it I mean for both were
the people I mean obviously you figure
that out that's what you're here but
most people know if they turn it in for
the first time they see how the Quran
memorized by millions all over the world
like no other book and what etc etcetera
but now how was it
how long and it takes time because we
take this some people who take it for
granted
they don't even know these facts but how
long it's like one fact to the next fact
and the next amazing discovery about it
you're like wow you know media is
telling me one thing though it's
opposite here Islam promotes love commit
compassion mercy you know it's not blind
faith I just wanna get excited you could
see talking about it I'm really amazed
when we just revisit those basic
principles of Islam it's amazing how
much time did you put in mom two months
not too long ago I had a guest on he was
talking about he studied it for like I
think was two years how much time did
you spend studying before you're like
you know what
and someone can take ten years study and
they still didn't accept you know
because there's also that courage that
you need it's a sincerity right how long
did it take before you were like okay
this is this is from the crater there's
no more gates there's no doubt about it
yeah I'd say less I'd say less than a
year for sure okay so let's so over six
months not quite a year so somewhere
around around 1011 months yeah and of
stuff of investigation
yeah of investigation I mean even after
I took Shahada I continued to learn what
I needed to know about Islam because
it's not always covered when you take
Shahada
yeah so you know I I did my own research
in it and that's when I was really firm
in it I mean initially when I was
growing up I always believed in God yeah
I always believed in the Creator but I
just didn't have a religion to place
that in hmm because I guess you know
from having the Mormon background and
just general Christian background
I really wasn't settled with it didn't
feel right to me it didn't fill all of
the questions that I that I had growing
up let's get into it we're gonna hold
that thought I want to get into covering
a little bit about the Mormon background
and then from there the other processes
that you went through your journey here
on the Dean show with Alexander
Alexander and we have a lot more to talk
about on this exciting episode don't go
anywhere right back
back here on addy show with Alexander
now you talk about the letters those
letters that Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him who we believe is
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind in a line of messengers
including Jesus Moses Abraham Noah and
all the other the the messengers that
the Prophet the Creator sent out of his
love out of his love he sent messengers
and those messengers came with the same
message worship the Creator not the
creation they came with the purpose of
life they warned people about the
accountability and the day of judgment
right and I'm just gonna just you know
turn to dust and I say go to sleep and
you're you know when life is oh no
people gonna be accountable for what
they did in this life and the message is
clear you also you spent almost a year
studying Islam finding you accepted it
but the journey continues it's like
always seeking knowledge and then you
appreciate this deed the more it's for
me it's like the more you study it the
more you're convinced about I had so
many different scholars of different
religions and the more they gained
proper understanding and they really
went deep into that religion they
figured this is a man-made religion
right and they got more knowledge of it
but more unconvinced that it was divine
but it seems to have the opposite effect
with Islam the more you study Islam the
more it has the effect on you that
there's no way that this can come from
Muhammad a group of man or any anybody
other than the one who created creation
and before that let's get into a little
bit of the history you said that you
mentioned the Mormon religion right yeah
so your parents Mormon yeah my mother
was Mormon it was probably around I was
like 8 maybe 9 years old I started going
to the church and that's a rough
estimate and it was three hours long and
what was three hours long the whole
service like for that Sunday or every
Sunday every Sunday three hours sermon
it was a you get not just a sermon they
were like it was divided into three
classes but there was like a mean thing
for everybody that's like did you MA
yeah yeah yeah so and then there were
smaller classes that broke
by way of like age groups yeah so but
yeah I was a deacon in the church for
you were a deacon in a church yeah oh
yeah Church yeah like when I got older
mm-hmm and that was that was short-lived
so what is this in the Mormon Church yes
okay so you oh wow I didn't know that so
you became a deacon in the Mormon Church
now what's the main difference between
Orthodox Christianity and the Mormon
Mormon Church I'd say that Joseph Smith
some like the Joseph Smith yeah he's
considered a prophet and they also have
modern-day prophets that I mean they
claim to be the prophets today and that
they receive like divine inspiration or
revelation from God yeah
and that's does definitely one of the
main one of the main aspects of Mormon
versus just a general Christian do they
still what about the concept of God of
Jesus being divine dying for your sins
that's still there and in Mormonism yes
yes yes it is and they believe they have
a Book of Mormon which apparently came
from you know Joseph Smith he had found
them there apparently it was during the
time of Jesus there was another book
called The Book of Mormon that was lost
that apparently he found mm-hmm from my
understanding yeah but what did that
entail you being a deacon in the Mormon
Church basically we we pass out the
bread like when it was time for
sacrament water and that's where they
start you to become like it's like the
beginning stages of coming to like
becoming a missionary but I never did
complete all of that I started to get
maybe it was because I was also young
and I was also like getting into high
school and all that
it started to not go to church anymore
mm-hmm
didn't want to was harder and harder for
my mom to get me up to do it so just
stopped going mm-hmm what is uh when you
go to the three hour session on what is
it Sunday's the mortgage what do they
call that their particular name for it
I'm not that I remember
okay so now did they have what would
would anyone be allowed to come like
anyone can come to the mosque on Friday
that's like every Friday
any time you can actually visit the the
the Muslims at the mosque you know come
in and to learn about Islam but let's
say Fridays Muslims are called to leave
off work and go for half an hour to
listen to the talk given hood bah and
from there this is supposed to like
recharge you for the week along with the
other things that we do and you usually
walk away if you came with the clear
message that there's only one God and
some of the basic principles of Islam of
doing good deeds you know developing a
relationship with the one who created
you did judgment and kind of a you know
recharging your heart on that you'd walk
away with that for sure right that's
always reiterated worship God alone
alone no one else but God right and
Muhammad is the last final messenger
accepted amongst other things but now
what do you walk away with from these
three our sermons what what do you
remember walking away with if someone
and with someone from the outside
allowed to come in on these
I didn't normally see that people would
come from the outside I didn't see it
from yourself I would assume that you
know I don't know if they take an
appointment I'm not sure but I normally
didn't see non-mormons you know that I
could you know tell off top that yeah
they were just visitors but what would
be the message someone can get away with
I'll get leave with coming to one of
those those for Sunday sessions I mean
for me I guess I I didn't get away with
much because this really didn't didn't
stick didn't stick you know
now you talk about later on did you end
up leaving Mormonism and you came more
towards Orthodox Christianity no I just
left religion altogether okay right
that's what usually happens people just
totally leave religion right so that's I
mean I didn't I didn't leave God
necessarily I always believed in the
creator like I said but but religion as
far as in general yeah I I just left it
on because now I was doing the typical
high school thing music and intoxicants
and that's what I would that's how I
grew up in high school yeah like just
not so much though chasing women or
anything like that but you know just my
friends my small group of friends and
toxic ends that's that's a sad reality
that's kind of like you know what you go
through if you don't have the proper
direction right you end up falling into
those pitfalls drugs alcohol partying
all right right absolutely yeah so what
what happens from there somewhere in
your story did you okay you get to a
point so you didn't disconnect from from
God right you still believed in a
creator so what happens from there
basically I get out of high school I
have a lot of issues with being a
headache to my parents so I definitely
spent some time staying at friends
houses staying on the streets even
sometimes and and and no direction still
believed in God this whole time didn't
necessarily pray I just so when I
started to meet my friend later on
through these non-muslim friends
he just revived that you know what was
already in me with as far as believing
in God and started to question it and
you know just basically rediscover that
you know that part of me is this a
Muslim that you're talking yeah yeah
what was his name who was this person
his name was Adam Adam yeah how did you
hook up with him I hooked up with him I
forgot exactly which non-muslim friends
we hooked up with but uh so he was
giving you downward now yeah he was
giving me dour not like full time like
it would it
I'm lumping conversation from time to
time he you generally made sure that
every time he met somebody he would tell
them about Islam yeah maybe not so
straightforward but it would you know to
be kind of subtle and he just yeah yeah
be subtle in depending on how you you
know react or how you respond he would
do yeah give you more or ask you also
you know what you think so yeah
and obviously the things that he was he
was sharing with you where they were
they things act sometimes you know
you'll hear these weird things things I
just don't make sense you don't hear
more of it but I mean with my experience
the the message of Islam is so powerful
right and you can't appreciate if your
ears are closed eyes are closed and
you're just like you know brainwashed by
the media but if you're hoping you're
receptive you're like hold on I want to
hear for myself and a little bit that
you do hear it's like I want to hear
some more right if you're sincere
absolutely that what was going on with
you yeah yeah absolutely I was uh I
definitely wanted to hear more I thought
because I remember one day that after
talking with him for some time I decided
to go out for a walk but before I did
that I was at home and I prayed to God
alone that I think that I was praying
too now and I would like to say that I
was sincere about really trying to find
what's true because he Adam was telling
me something other people were telling
me other things things that I was
reading were telling me different things
you know so basically what I thought to
myself was like either all the religions
are wrong or there is one that is
correct you know and I was just I I
believe I was in Syria when I asked God
to show me what the right path was so
then I left my house took a short walk
ran into some Jews for Jesus over
downtown where I was living and that's
what I thought that was the sign yeah
hold on let's see we're gonna take a
break that's interesting Jews for Jesus
let's just give up right there and come
back to rest of his amazing story don't
go anywhere
back here on addy shall we left off
where you ran you made okay this is very
important so we're a dissecting kind of
your story and seeing where we can
derive some benefits and I think this is
really profound some simple and someone
just the most simple and basic things
are overlooked by people but there
that's right there that's where your
remedy is that's where the solution is
that's where the power is and some of
these simple basic things that you just
did and many people are not doing you
pray to God alone right not to the
creation nothing not to a Jesus Mohammed
no by just to the Creator you prayed
right right and you asked for some
direction guidance right and we believe
firmly if you're sincere with yourself
with God with the Creator right you
don't have an image of God not a
painting not a statue notice nothing
it's just the one who is above who
created creation above current he's
running creation the one who created
Jesus and this whole universe and
everything in it you prayed to him and
now you bump into Jews for Jesus the
Jews for Jesus how does that work so I
mean basically they were outside giving
their Dawa yeah and calling people to
their way but uh and I didn't really
know what was going on with with them
but for some reason after I had prayed
and left and I thought that was you know
naturally I thought that was like okay
this is it right here yeah so I know
they gave me a Bible and they gave me
like a little cross to wear or something
like a little cheap cross to wear yeah
and I came came home with that stuff and
started to read the Bible and my brother
said something basically disapproving of
it or or he was just like thought it was
silly that I was like engaging myself an
older brother younger banger brother
younger brother was he into any religion
at all it was human um I think at the
time he was like into Buddhism or
something like but he wasn't telling me
to follow that but he was just like now
I mean like yeah I forgot exactly what
he had said but and then I and then I
kind of agreed with him I guess I kind
of like you know followed suit with what
he was saying yeah but I can ended up
coming back to Adam
and we have been talking with him until
you know like he invited me to the
mosque so he kind of took me by the hand
to come to the mosque I didn't say like
yes I want to go right now or anything
he's like so would you want to come to
the mosque I said sure yeah so you know
he kind of led me there and took Shahada
with some witnesses yeah and then he
asked me if I felt any different and I
said I mean not really but a little bit
you know and then like it wasn't until
much later that I started to read and
all that
I wouldn't say much later but sometime
later I started to read and all that and
it felt like like veils kept being
lifted from my eyes as I started to know
more and more about Islam so you see the
world differently it felt like I started
to see a different you know I started to
see like wow there's a lot of people who
don't know this yeah you know and you
know it's it's real it's real it's
that's a lot of peace in my heart to be
able to know that you know what's gonna
what's gonna eventually happen after you
know everything is said and done and
we're in the graves yeah so that's
important that you you mentioned that
yes you'd you feeling any different
many many people after they take Shahada
and how there's simply that declaration
of faith obviously for the people who
don't know is is testifying declaring
what's in your heart let it come out
with your lips if you love your wife you
love your mother you tell them I love
you right right you testified to it
you'd have no problem testifying if
someone stole your wallet and the police
needed a description said who's the
person who took it I'll testify right in
court right you testify so now you know
that who's your creator Allah the one
who created creation Allah that's my
Creator
Muhammad is messenger testified to it
and what was the problem so you you
testify that there's nothing worthy of
worship so the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah and Muhammad is his last
and final messenger and amazing thing is
this wouldn't exclude but it would
include all the preceding messengers
obviously Jesus Moses Abraham and
all the other messengers and from there
many people they feel like a weight has
been lifted off them but not necessarily
that you're like you know something
mystical and you're waiting for this
experience nah but now you know your
purpose and that that it's like a
riddles been solved right you have some
direction in life so you're enlightened
right yeah so that's a distinguishing
factor because some people they search
for that yeah there's a good feeling you
feel like you know weight has been
lifted you feel like you know because
when you do accept Islam all your
previous sins are absolved you send free
write often say if you hold somebody
something you got to make sure you pay
that debt but from there with God you're
right right right but this is important
now you continued on seeking knowledge
and the veils now it's like okay
now I can see it's like persons in the
dark and they just run for this
temporary world but now you can see like
how to be a better neighbor about how
you can be a better human being all
around right go to your parents better
worshiper with God and there's hope now
for the end with all trials and
calamities there's a reward Jenna
paradise what we're striving for we
don't get attached in this temporary
life so there's direction now there's
purpose and that and that just gives
that gives the heart it strengthens the
heart makes a person stronger and more
committed but that what you said it
takes more reading it takes more
studying it takes commitment absolutely
yeah because I remember when I told him
when I took Shahada he asked me how I
felt and I said I didn't feel me I
believed in the words that I said yeah
but I it's not like like you were
mentioning some examples earlier like a
white light was coming down or something
or you know but yeah it took some time
and I think that's what's important for
new Muslims especially they won't always
find everybody to take them by the hand
to teach them what they need to know a
lot of the time you got to really I mean
some people you might have one or two
who might really like push you to do it
yourself or will take you by the hand
of you but you really have to like you
know do a lot of self-study yeah you
know you have to you have to go and seek
it mm-hmm just like you saw it the first
time to become Muslim yeah you have to
seek how to really be a Muslim
afterwards you know saying yeah it's
like anything in life but I mean when
you you can make the we can make these
small comparisons but if you've decided
that this is the best University that
you can attend and you're going to
benefit from everything it has to offer
it's gonna take you a to make the
commitment to sign up now but just
because you sign up you're not gonna
have all the knowledge that it has to
offer our benefit until you start
implementing and the same thing with
Islam
all right you haveyou realizes the truth
now you submitted to that truth but now
the faith the benefits come after you
implement the truth see people miss
Tennessee they try to you know get all
the benefits first no you've got to
first submit to it which your Creator
wants you to do start implementing it
and now your face starts to increase
alright you start to grow you start to
benefit from everything that Allah has
told us to do and you reap the rewards
yeah and being sincere you know like I
can't express the sincerity more because
like a lot of people like they say some
people will say that they would like to
know the truth you know they would like
to you know if there was a creator or
whatever that they would like to have
knowledge of that but you know it
depends like like a lot of people like
if you're just even I think even if I'm
in a lot of cases I might be wrong but
even if you're just like a little bit
insincere like you really you kind of
don't care like a lot of people don't
care there's so many distractions music
TV you know work school families what
you do on your off time that can just
keep you distracted you can just keep
one thing after another and so you're
not really thinking about it and and I
think if you're a hundred percent
sincere about really trying to find the
truth God and God will definitely you
know make it available to you pardon me
yes sir d you got to be sincere you got
to want it just like you wanted that man
or woman right you chase that person
just like you wanted that job you chased
it you got you wanted that car whatever
you wanted a material things these are
material things right
you chased it you fought for it you
sought for and you got it this is the
test now are you willing to do the same
even half that much to acquire the truth
to connect with your Creator but like
you said people are distracted
Entertainment all these other things are
more important and that's what's going
to show and testify at the end when you
die and the reward of paradise there and
the Hellfire is there J judgement what
is in the test now it's like hold on the
people who studied the people who put in
a time they passed the people who didn't
and God is all just he sends messenger
he says the warning but people turn away
a blind eye so who can you blame but
yourself right yeah so what what uh
we're almost time just flies by so what
piece of advice would you say from your
long journey now obviously another thing
it's a whole different topic but the
struggle continues right so what what
advice do you give for people who are
kind of and these stories are meant to
enlighten people who are kind of
struggling they realize by listening to
your story that you're not you an Arab
no no okay
you were born where you an American
Brazilian someone you know my parents of
Brazilian I was born in Chicago Oh
Chicago yeah so Islam is is a universal
way of life it's not because some people
many people think all if you're Muslim
you're an Arab so we dispelled that myth
you're an American many people like
they'll pick a foreign car over an
American one because the quality let's
say of Honda's better Toyota for example
or Mercedes but that doesn't mean
they're a traitor to their country does
it so just because you want to worship
the Creator not the creation right you
want to submit your will to God doesn't
that isn't just doesn't mean you're a
traitor right you still love your
country I'm sure I love mine and we want
the best for humanity so people see
these things right but some people are
struggling they think okay man I'm gonna
be outcast outside or what advice to you
from someone who was
investigating Islam now you're living it
and what if I simplifies to you get four
four people who are kind in that dilemma
like you know they're nervous what
society is gonna say what my parents
gonna say you know and some people
accepted Islam now they're struggling
struggling with it there's a lot there
to cover just some basic yeah ya know I
would say just I can't put sincerity or
you can't make somebody sincere so try
to find the sincerity within yourself to
look for the truth if it is important to
you it's there it's not like it's not
hidden either yeah just gotta be sincere
about finding it and and and continue to
research because Islam always you know
in the Quran Allah asks you to a
question and ask into and to do research
and reflect so to continue to do that
and and be sincere and and shell out
you'll that's and with that be sincere I
like that that's the key right that you
gotta be sincere yeah absolutely thank
you thank you thank you for being with
us my God Almighty bless you and thank
you guys for tuning in here to the Deen
show sincerity is key you got to
sincerely want to know the truth you got
a search for it and ask ask and you
shall receive so ask the one who created
you say the one who created me why am I
here what do you want from me guide me
is that simple but often it's overlooked
so start earnestly asking the one who
created you don't put a middle man in
between you and your Creator beseech him
alone and then from there start
investigating start researching remember
death it's gonna come at any time you
have all these aspirations and goals
okay shoot form but remember prepare for
it's gonna come possibly before you even
achieve most of those goals death and
what when it comes what excuse are you
gonna have that you chased everything
under the Sun you accomplished every
goal except the ultimate goal figuring
out what the purpose of life is why am I
here where am I going when I die and how
you can you expect to get paradise the
ultimate reward promised to those who
believe
in the one God and do what he told him
to do of good deeds you can't get
anything you can't expect to get that
reward if you didn't chase it so tune in
every week to the D show start with
these simple steps call us
you